Transcriber: TED Translators Admin
Reviewer: Mirjana Čutura
Humans do not see trees.
They walk by us every day.
They sit and sleep, smoke and picnic
and secretly kiss in our shade.
They pluck our leaves
and gorge on our fruits.
They break our branches
or carve their lover's name
on our trunks with their blades
and vow eternal love.
They weave necklaces out of our needles
and paint our flowers into art.
They split us into logs
to heat their homes,
and sometimes they chop us down
just because they think
we obstruct their view.
They make cradles, wine corks,
chewing gum, rustic furniture
and produce the most
beautiful music out of us.
And they turn us into books
in which they bury themselves
on cold winter nights.
They use our wood to manufacture coffins
in which they end their lives.
And they even compose
the most romantic poems for us,
claiming we're the link
between earth and sky.
And yet, they do not see us.
So one of the many beauties
of the art of storytelling
is to imagine yourself
inside someone else's voice.
But as writers, as much as
we love stories and words,
I believe we must also
be interested in silences:
the things we cannot talk
about easily in our societies,
the marginalized, the disempowered.
In that sense, literature can,
and hopefully does,
bring the periphery to the center,
make the invisible a bit more visible,
make the unheard a bit more heard,
and empathy and understanding speak louder
than demagoguery and apathy.
Stories bring us together.
Untold stories and entrenched
silences keep us apart.
But how to tell the stories
of humanity and nature
at a time when our planet is burning
and there is no precedent
for what we're about
to experience collectively
whether it's political,
social or ecological?
But tell we must
because if there's one thing
that is destroying our world
more than anything,
it is numbness.
When people become disconnected,
desensitized, indifferent,
when they stop listening,
when they stop learning
and when they stop caring
about what's happening
here, there and everywhere.
We measure time differently,
trees and humans.
Human time is linear --
a neat continuum
stretching from a past
that is deemed to be over and done with
towards the future that is supposed
to be pristine, untouched.
Tree time is circular.
Both the past and the future
breathe within the present moment.
And the present does not move
in one direction.
Instead it draws circles within circles,
like the rings you would find
when you cut us down.
Next time you walk by a tree,
try to slow down and listen
because each of us whispers in the wind.
Look at us.
We're older than you and your kind.
Listen to what we have to tell,
because hidden inside our story
is the past and the future of humanity.